thank you
[Music]
so every now and then we like to report
some pretty good news Okay so a bunch of
people died at no just kidding oh it's
like that there was an overdose
prevention vending machine what has
stopped hundreds of deaths from fentanyl
in Cincinnati yeah but then what if
you're like you don't have enough money
for the vending machine and then you die
wait how does that provide you just like
narcon in it it's a vending machine that
is holding testing kits right yeah Oh I
thought it was like an EpiPen you're
just dying from fentanyl [__] you're
like I need it and then it's seven and
it goes
[Laughter]
yeah what if it was a claw machine
you could earn it you're like [__] I had
a claw machine so uh from February to
November in 2021 a call center
registered 637 Anonymous people for the
prop uh for the program giving them an
access code to the vending machine which
then distributed
3360 and now toxin Doses and 10 155
fentanyl test strips
located in Hamilton County Ohio people
be [__] with that fentanyl huh but
they do it to make sure they got
fentanyl
the testing objectives they do deals in
front of it they're like let me see
they're like dude this my barely got any
fat though
you get no I'm not gonna die from this
it's weak [__] there are people that can
[__] handle it really really yeah
stronger than that now I wonder what
their dosage is that noise crazy because
that [__] kills people what is fentanyl
for like killing it's to make it it's to
make drugs more potent for less money
right but originally right you're like
originally like isn't it like a medical
useful oh there's Fentanyl and um
epidurals like when people are about to
give labor
get flavor or what do you do labor gifts
fentanyl is a synthetic opioid according
to the diet uh fentanyl is a synthetic
opioid that is 50 to 100 times stronger
than morphine but yeah so it is
pharmaceutical fentanyl is developed for
pain management treatment of cancer Etc
blah blah blah so it's just a hundred
times stronger than more the strongest
pain killer ever yeah
damn that make you feel no pain to the
end but to stop the pain you're stopping
like [__] The receptors and [__] from
working so it probably stops a lot of
[__] from working that's why I just
meditate
last time I had a [__] stomach ache
it was so bad and I was like you know
why it's because you thinking about this
[__] too much shut the [__] up
and it went away yeah I did that with a
headache one time really yeah you told
that [__] not until it's shut up but I
just [__] I just turned on [__] uh
what's his name Deepak Chopra or
whatever the hell oh he's relaxing yeah
yeah when you hear like a calming voice
and you start focusing on other [__]
yeah it's like you forget dude yeah hmm
it's crazy and then you go ah [__] it
came back as soon as he's done I'm like
ah [__]
so this vending machine is credited for
the reduction in drug uh overdose deaths
as well as HIV incidents
um university uh wait that stops HIV no
no I think just the reduction of it uh
it says it's uh oh so before you have
sex with someone you gotta be like hey
take this trip
foreign
[Laughter]
they're basically describing this method
as harm reduction which acknowledges
that some people always have used drugs
and probably always will even if they're
potentially lethal in large doses uh
harm reduction as University of
Cincinnati press describes is a paradigm
that does not support or enable drug use
but instead aims to empathetically meet
people where they are in their course of
the drug use and help Empower them to
take steps which minimize the potential
hazards associated with its use that's
kind of cool yeah
so why not yeah and the idea of the
vending machine specifically is also a a
program that
um kind of like lets participants feel
that you know they're far away from
prying eyes or judgmental glances right
because it's just your uh your
relationship with that [__] machine
you know what I mean yeah oh that's true
nobody's looking at your [__] yeah shame
free drug testing yeah that that would
be the best way to do it drug testing
this thing about how some 7-Elevens that
are in the desert that are close to meth
uh meth lab trailers they'll sell the
Pyrex like uh Beaker and funnel like in
a package deal whoa because I know
people are buying it for that reason or
the little rules like a crazy glass pipe
yeah they'll be like it'll it'll just be
bundled because they know that if you
cook meth you buy all of those things so
they'll it'll be like a 7.99 bundle and
it's all the [__] you need discounts and
savings I bet those mad dealers are like
man like 7-Eleven
yeah there was like cool photos of it
and [__] people are like how the [__]
but it's like they're the dudes are just
like oh people always buy these things
so maybe we'll just bundle it do you
think the store owners know like they're
just like I think they kind of kind of
know right people like to buy these in
combination
maybe I'll just put it as a set that's
good business though isn't it well like
in this in this vending machine actually
uh it says uh it has naloxone which is a
drug that can counteract opioid
overdoses it has test strips that can
test drugs like heroin that can
potentially contain Fentanyl and it also
has safer injection kits tourniquets and
bandages oh wow so it's like all across
the board like save your life
the uh like if you're a heroin addict
they have a doctor give it to you or
something like that my trip they
administer it yeah am I tripping maybe I
mean it could make sense it was like I
felt like I've heard that about some
place I think some place either in like
Norway or the Orlando Scandinavian yeah
they have one where it's like instead of
getting it off the streets you can get a
lower uh potent but pharmaceutical grade
version and clean syringes so that so
you don't spread disease yeah and you
don't have to go into crime and all that
they're trying to do that stuff in La
too and they have shelters some of them
will have shelters you can just do it
right here here so it feels safer it's a
safe space yeah give you some clean
needles wow
yeah but they do it to you they're like
this is the dose you got to take I think
they give you um a kit a little kit and
you do it yourself because they don't
want that Joy away from you yeah yeah
it's like Korean it's like Korean
barbecue I want to cook the meat yeah I
got two homies coming in like this and
then the ladies they're like do you mind
they want to do this together every time
you inject me I'll inject you
like [__] this is good stuff do they do
weddings like that where they [__] it
that's that's how they do it yeah that's
how they do their bounce
they're just suck it
I just like the uh the kind of like uh
perspective and the communication that
this uh company puts out too they're
saying like if you're interested in
stopping we're here to help but if not
we aren't going to turn you away and
refuse to help we're going to work with
you and help you take steps that will
help keep you safe I like where he went
I like the transition sentimental
you were reading it more shame yeah
shame more shame no that is that is kind
of jump though this is only in
Cincinnati uh this is currently in
Cincinnati because of a company that's
out there I mean at the time the study
was published clients reported 288
overdoses were reversed with a naloxone
and a number which almost reached a
thousand by the time this writing more
than two-thirds of those who re-enrolled
after their first enrollment detected
fentanyl president and the drugs they
were consuming
um so just you know same way people are
going to do it anyway but if you can get
safer cleaner drugs or like have access
then there's definitely going to be less
deaths so with the the overturn of the
overdose
so basically if someone passes out and
you can obviously tell it's an OD they
give them something like Pulp Fiction
naloxone uh is said to like counteract
the opioid that like can lead to
overdoses so I'm I don't know if this
has like Extreme as like there's already
an overdose in place or if somebody's
beginning to either yeah yeah it's like
something just to have yeah or if you
take it before you do the actual heroin
is it like that it might be just like
you can buy it in preventative cases
like Benadryl before your alcohol yeah
maybe kind of people do that I like
Naruto drill before your alcohol I don't
know what that is
well I don't know if it works but like
some there's certain people that go like
man or Zyrtec or different things that
get your you know because Asian glow or
something you know people that have like
the uh allergic reaction to alcohol yeah
yeah so so they'll take that
um you're allergic to alcohol yeah every
time I drink anything I turn like beet
red I look like this [__] bag of
questions which is why a lot of people
take things like Zyrtec or tagameters I
have no idea that was a thing oh [__] or
I just don't drink maybe that's bad yeah
it is because if you get Asian glow
you're highly likely to have some issues
with heart problems and liver problems
and stuff if you drink oh [__] boring
[Music]